-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging with our pal
Kevin James, who stars in the
new Netflix film "Home Team."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's coming out tomorrow.
I want to ask you also about
another project
that you're doing.
You did a local production
of "Oliver."
-Yes. Yeah, I took a page out of
Sean Payton's playbook.
I did a --
My kids were asking me
if I could be
in a play with them.
So I said, "Yeah, I would love
to do a small part
where I just come in and say
hello kind of"
and have a little fun
in the play with them.
It turned out to be --
We did "Oliver."
I'd never seen "Oliver" but I'm
playing Fagin in "Oliver,"
which is a pretty big part, man.
I didn't know
how involved it was.
It's the hardest
I've ever worked for
anything in my career.
I'm honest.
Have you ever done live theater?
-Never. No, no, no.
I couldn't remember the lines.
-Exactly.
Well, you can sing, though.
You can dance.
There's all of this in there.
And I'm just --
I'm horrendous with it.
And it was like --
It's frightening.
And these kids are amazing.
The whole group is really good,
so there's a lot
of pressure on me.
And we had some fun doing it.
But I'm just not, you know,
a musical guy and all that.
It's literally the hardest --
Double rehearsals,
like tech week.
The whole thing, live audience.
It's a panic fest.
-Do your kids school you
to any new music?
Do you get to hear music
through your kids?
-I hear tons of music now.
I mean,
the radio's always going along.
-Anything you're listening to
now?
-The one song that's in my head
constantly is
the one that -- buh-buh-duh-duh.
F you.
[ Laughter ]
-How dare you.
How dare you say that to me?!
-Are you kidding me?!
-No, I'm not kidding you at all.
-I'll throw at you!
[ Laughter ]
-You want to sit down?!
You want to sit down?! Sit down!
[ Laughter ]
Sit down!
-Oh, yeah!
-Yeah!
-You got to be kidding me, man.
-Oh, yeah?
-How about a little bit of this
you little --
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah! Yeah!
-Your movie's on Netflix, huh?
Well, guess what!
I'm logged in and the password's
in there!
-Hey!
This is your computer?!
How you getting any work done?!
Is this where
you type your jokes?
-Oh, yeah?
Don't get wet, buddy!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Dude, dude, that is not cool!
-Yeah, it's not cool at all,
man!
Nothing's cool anymore!
-Yeah?
How about a sack of nickels?
[ Coins jingling ]
You want nickels in the face
with an old sweat sock?!
[ Laughter ]
-You're lucky you missed me with
that one!
Is your movie about football?
-Yeah, it's about football!
-Yeah, well, here's something
that was on my foot!
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wait a second.
-Oh, my gosh, I'm thinking about
this now.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I just remembered.
No, no, no.
It's not "F you."
It's "abcdefu."
It's that song by Gayle.
[ Applause ]
-Oh.
-Oh!
-My God.
-You know that one?
-What am I doing?
What are we doing?!
I'm so sorry.
I love you, Kevin.
I would never want to
do this to you.
-I love you, man.
-Thanks, buddy. I appreciate it.
-Yeah.
But I do have to give you this,
okay?
-No, no, no, no, no!
Gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-Did I miss you?
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Banana cream, my favorite.
My thanks to Kevin James!
His new film "Home Team"
premieres tomorrow on Netflix.
I love you, buddy.
We'll be right back with
more "Tonight Show."